I'm Joshua dinar I wrote and starred in
sealing your fate I'm with you Jacob I'm
the director of silica fait cela fait is
the project that chest and heart roped
and he brought it to me about three
years ago da da years ago and we
couldn't logistically figure out how to
do it without costing us as much as it
comes to make a feature so we decided to
wait until a better time which came when
i went to the NIA chrome Academy shout
out quick and we were able to do the
project more efficiently
acad with their equipment and Josh yeah
the time off between we wouldn't we
initially set out to make the film too
when we actually made it was was a real
blessing now we're able to get Keith
David to be in the project as well as
Isaac singleton jr. and credit to
Michael saying the our producer for that
and it's just a much better film as a
result definitely I mean I think we
became we were better in the entry or
some on a three-year off a time off oh
no oh my signaling the time of we became
better filmmakers which helped us out we
brought them over here from film courage
tonight the show before miles makers a
spare change which is a really cool
movie and cool new the idea our movie
about suing invade assuming your fate is
basically I guess we'd say a comedy
about what happens when you let jealousy
get in the way of trust in a
relationship and how it can essentially
seal your fate I think in the
relationship I pretty much everybody can
deal with that an egg at the time
jealousy kind of gets everyone